amazon
deciding to go into podcasts okay so
launching into podcasting wednesday
becoming the latest
entrant to the rapidly expanding medium
is amazon
amazon music has more than 70 000
podcasts to start including dj khaled
while the library is significantly
smaller than apple's over 1 million
podcast or spotify's 1.5 million podcast
amazon is launching with popular titles
including crime junkie
what a day radio lab revisionist history
planet money and stuff you should know
while the company is joining a
competitive field
executives said the service can tack
differently
from rivals as it has with music
streaming and bring
in new podcast listeners particularly
through its voice activated home
speakers
thoughts on amazon going into podcast
you know are those the scariest words
you could ever hear
in an industry amazon has decided to go
right because there's nothing you could
do whatever you know they've taken their
time they've they've been very very
methodical in doing this
so they've got something up their sleeve
it sounds like it's opening you know
us uk germany and japan primarily right
away they got big names dj khaled
did i pronounce that right i shouldn't
talk about no you did a great time okay
good i practiced
uh dan patrick will smith you know
anything will smith is touching
is going to work the way that guy has
his smith's going to do a podcast
well he he and his wife have i'm sure a
whole network we got something going on
we'll see i mean but they're going to do
it very very well spotify's shares
sunk just on the news alone be
interesting what
what amazon can do that's going to be
different though is jeff bezos going to
have a podcast are people going to
listen to that i would imagine they
would if he offered up some some gossip
from his personal life or
some business bezos is doing a podcast
however i i do agree with your point
for sure if amazon is jumping into
anything
i'm i'd be fearful you just said spotify
stock went down yeah
totally but go ahead did you have a
response no no i mean i actually agree
with
you
just want to say i agree and make this a
wonderfully happy hey everything that
time
today i agree we're just going to have a
total compliance
you guys get off this podcast today's
going to be everywhere
what are you doing listening to this
book guys i don't even know why i'm here
okay so tell us what do you what points
do you have that we haven't heard from
tom
a couple key points tell us the company
is joining the highly competitive field
we got that right
but like tom said if amazon's joining
this competitive field if i'm a
competitor
i'd be very scared i would say if
there's two things that amazon is going
to start focusing on
by the way they're killing it in
everything they do yeah if they're going
to join the
podcast world you know competing with
the spotifys of the world
i think there's a higher likelihood that
they're gonna crush that field
versus competing with the elon musk
uh spacex type of exploration and why is
that do you have a reason for that
i just think it's more their niche i
think it's more their fit i think you
know
i was hoping we're going to go deeper
than that yeah i was hoping your
cinnamon hot chocolate
coffee that you had this morning was
going to bring out the look you know and
and the dmt stuff that we were talking
about
they got the alexa they got the i mean
listen when i walk into my office now
you're talking yeah i'm going
i'm telling you you cut me off you cut
me out now go get to your point
so i mean obviously they're they're
massive place they got
data galore i walk into my office right
there alexa play travis scott
boom travis scott is being played so you
walk into your office you're like
alexa play the patrick beck david
podcast boom now we're playing it
alexa play the jeff bezos podcast uh tom
zender's new favorite podcast
so i think that's where they're going
with this and it's just a data play
and they're going to dominate whatever
they do here's here's what i will tell
you i
i think uh one i don't even think the
podcast world has even started yet
i think there's million to me it's
nothing there's 7.7 billion
people in the world one million podcasts
means nothing
okay as far as how many podcasts are
being done today uh there's still a lot
of great people that could crush it in
the podcast world that haven't gone into
it
there's a lot of creative people that
have not gone to podcast world
but this is the one thing you have to
keep in mind so if
for example the three of us were to get
into real estate
okay all three of us have you ever done
real estate i've never done real estate
yeah so
let's just say the three of us become
realtors all three of us become realtors
you're in manhattan you're in miami i do
california socal and i do some dallas
hypothetically i do socal in dallas okay
who are the first people when you make
your list you're going to contact about
selling them home in
in miami who's your market i'm going to
call my athletes i'm going to call my uh
my friends with families and kids yeah
people what have you done
with the money 14 years what have you
been doing last four years life
insurance settlement so you're going to
call your life insurance clients
you're going to call some of your life
settlements no what i mean is
the people you deal with the agents
you're dealing with financial advice who
are you going to call it high net worth
people
anybody i know that has money and that's
going to spend and then i can talk into
something
but specific what industry that you've
been in for a long time i've been in the
media business so you're probably going
to call your contacts immediately
michael jordan yeah and you're gonna say
what listen guys i'm doing real estate
yeah hey it's tom how you doing good
look i just want to give you an update
i'm in a real estate business now and
i'm selling homes i'm not selling you
know i'm selling real estate now
then you contact them yeah what's my
point here amazon
has 10 million authors
they have 10 million authors that need
to sell their books
and amazon's gonna say guess what on
your
author central website with your
books put your podcast right here
because the moment someone's done
listening to your podcast and they like
it
they can buy your book they got 10
million authors
potentially that could be creating
content for them because amazon's going
to go to what they already have a
database uh
it's authors a ton of them and they need
to sell books and many of them the way
they make money is
purely selling books i think amazon's
got a already a
deep enough you know what do you call a
database of people that could create
content
i think they'll be competing and pat
think about this too alexa already knows
what you like and what you want
so she's gonna be able to tell you
what's available i mean they're
programming two people
specifically already because they know
everything about you here's the bigger
question
what couldn't amazon go into could they
open a restaurant
a restaurant i mean what's next for them
is there anything that they would touch
that wouldn't be successful
i mean everything i mean this kind of
surprised people i think it makes
perfect sense i don't think anybody was
expecting it but it does make you wonder
what's next and what couldn't they do
i'm not surprised by amazon going into
podcast though at all like i'm not
i'm surprised that they haven't gone in
yet that's that's what i'm surprised
with
i'm not surprised that they're going
into it i think it's a good move yeah
being the key word because they could
have done this a long time that's the
part
yet is the key part that goes back to my
original point this is not shocking to
me it'd be
it's way more fit for them versus trying
to compete with the spacex's of the
world space exploration
versus podcasts i think i think there's
those are two different reasonings
podcast is just business we got to do it
yeah it's it's a product that we can put
on the shelf hey we're walmart
there's these new towels that came up
put them on the shelf let's go we got to
sell it hey we got tvs we got a podcast
on the show put the podcast on the shelf
spacex is there's no way elon musk is a
better entrepreneur than me
that's what space that's the competitive
nature spacex is who's dating the
prettier girl spacex is measuring your
better basketball game you're better you
know it's spacex is a little bit more
uh a manly competition it has nothing
think about what you just said pat
take it does everyone in the audience
just think about this for a second
here we go we are now talking about
competing
entrepreneurs competing over going to
space
yeah that's where we're at right now in
2020 oh you think you're gonna go to the
moon buddy i'll meet you on mars
that's where we're at right now that's
wild stuff right there
[Music]